she's used to being
or what you find is that she used to
being treated by guys a certain type of
way she's used to being talked to a
certain type of way doesn't that say
something about the man she picks
exactly yeah like doesn't that say
something about her because she pick him
no it does yeah it does it does and it
was like what we were saying earlier
it's not just the amount of uh men women
sleep with it's the men who they sleep
with because sometimes as men it's it's
not even that say say oh my God and you
sleep with someone I know it might not
just be that it's someone I know I know
that guy I know who he slept with
and that translate through to us so
that's part of it you know you know he's
a lame you yeah do you know I mean you
can you can like a girl and you just
just from the person that she slept with
you know that she doesn't think yes
logically you slept with him yeah so is
it better that you're because okay I
think in two ways right okay is it
better that the girl slept with a lame
or something with a guy that's better
than you
like I I would say for me personally if
a girl goes out she can go and tell
people she slept with me and there's
nobody who can turn around and be like
what you slept with Roe because I know
me personally there's no one out there
that's going to be like oh he's a lame
or he's done this or he's this type of
person whereas there are certain dudes
out there when you hear that a girl
slept with them you just think nah this
girl's not got her head screwed up so so
it's interesting though because I think
that in order for a girl to truly love
you she has to look at you as the best
she can do
and so if her ex is better than you like
she doesn't want you she wants him he
just probably like rejected her and so
it's like like she's gonna view you as
she settled exactly if my girl cheats on
me with someone that's less than in
whatever respect then
then it comes down to
but I think partly at least what I've
done I've I've done I've messed up in
some way because if she's gone below me
she's dropped her standard below me then
yeah something's gone wrong here if
she's going to go and do that as you
said go above I'm not gonna like it but
I understand
so what do you guys think can you turn a
hoe into a housewife
oh wait so sorry so you're saying if she
slept with someone that is better than
you that's more acceptable no no I'm not
gonna like it but I I get it at least at
least if you're gonna do that at least
you leveled up so then so a hoe is
someone that slept with lots of people
so that's what we're saying
a home is a woman that slept with a lot
of men like her body count is up she's
she slept with a lot of men and that is
the term for us yeah a very very quickly
as well without much situation or or
circumstance around it just they've had
there's a lot of things around it so
yeah all of the above so if all the men
that she was sleeping with were better
than you does that still make her a hoe
yeah I mean a hoe is a hoe you sleep
with a lot of men you're a hoe like but
then all the men were of like more
valuable like they wasn't matter so yeah
a whole like the term hoe is pretty
simple you know you sleep with a lot of
men you are considered a hoe but that
I'm just saying if this hoe has set them
lots of men that were better than you
can she be turned to a housewife or like
I said I believe it is her choice I
don't believe a man can turn a hoe into
a housewife she has to choose she has to
choose whether she wants to turn and
that lifestyle she wants to give that
lifestyle up
I don't believe girls I don't believe
them like because they always
conveniently stop being a hose at like
30. and it's like that's kind of
convenient you found God this year right
when time's running out 20 it's like 27
to 30 and now you join the church where
were you at 20
.
living alive yeah that's what I'm saying
like they conveniently learn their
lesson when like time's running out so I
just don't but like if she does it at 21
you know maybe like okay yeah okay I
could yeah but a 20 year old hoe can be
turned to a housewife but no not really
no I occasionally but not not really no
I just think a housewife is top 20 of
women most girls don't get to be
Housewives and so it's like if you're a
hoe you get the outcome of like the best
women I doubt it
you gotta remember being a hoe is also a
mentality as well it's everything based
on I can use my sexuality my looks how I
you know everything based around that is
nothing else about her character as a
woman or being a woman that she can use
to bag or snag or impress on the man
it's literally all on her looks as well
so that goes into it as well and which
is what you two said earlier was unfair
and what what did I say you guys were
talking about you know men just focusing
on looks a lot of 304s do use that with
sexuality their sexuality is the
deduction
the looks so yeah but we well did we say
you said us two said no no use earlier
when we was talking and we was talking
about things that like values yeah
exactly yeah you you guys were kind of
offended when we were mentioning that so
I'm just saying certain 304s they
literally only bring that that's another
thing in it as well they literally only
just bring their looks and sensuality
there's nothing else to them that they
can bring
of value to a man or relationship so I'm
just saying I think that is possible I
think that
the cutoff point is like 20. I think if
he was a [__] before he was 20 I think
it's still possible because I've seen
some young girls that they've done a lot
of things they were young for one reason
the upper bad upbringing or whatever and
they've just turned their life around
fantastic I asked wife cool again they
chose to yeah but nobody turned them
into it they decided you know what this
ain't for me but
I I personally say the cutoff point I'd
say is about 20. I think the older you
get and the more [__] you get the
harder it is I think we potentially
everyone can be a hole was housewife
potentially just about yes I think it
depends
I was good I was like fat chicks don't
get to be happy
that's not I want to be look I want to
talk about you no you go ahead what did
you say no I'm saying I think it depends
on the man because if the if the man is
high value enough the woman's not gonna
stray or continue being a whole chicken
she's gonna keep in mind that's what I
think if you love and admire respect
this man you do not want to leave you
don't want to [__] up this relationship
you don't think there's tendencies that
she's gained over time that is not the
right man
yeah see if she if she has the right man
in front of her she's going nowhere
you're playing the you're playing a
dangerous game yeah right because you're
you're gambling on an investment not me
personally I'm not taking that risk
right I'm saying it's possible he's
betting on the injured horse
I'm saying it's possible he got that car
off of Craigslist
and the question was is it possible
that's why and I'm saying yes it's
possible is it probable but not probably
I'm saying that's what I'm saying I'm
saying it's impossible you're saying
impossible yes because I believe a woman
will have gained certain tricks things
that she's learned over time habits we
will have going into whatever
relationship a woman's a hypergamous so
she's been living a certain lifestyle
exactly Behavior yeah
how is she going to come down
to a man she wants to settle with
but why actually why why is she coming
that's what I'm saying if she's come
across a high value man yes that she
does not want to leave like you said
women are hypergamous yes why would she
why would she [__] up that relationship
because she's had variety she's had all
but she's met the one have you heard
that song that she's not there
she's met the six foot guy she's met the
guy who's got money she's met the guy
who's finally he's Charming why would
you cheat I'm saying I'm saying it's
possible
women in the world you're saying it's
impossible um I'll explain there's
always going to be someone that's bigger
or better than you in some way shape or
forming this is just life you will never
be Top Dog someone will overpass you in
some way shape or form and she as a
hypergamist will jump we also we all saw
the that's not true of um Jeff Bezos and
Leonardo DiCaprio right we all saw that
clip the richest man in the world so and
yeah but you say that's what I said
earlier just because you've got money
don't
all the boxes she's going nowhere yeah
but you yeah exactly but this is the
dude Richard Bezos is a [__] man yeah
Jeff I mean Jeff basil sorry